russia's war came to a shoe factory in
central ukraine
a rare attack for the city of nipro
not so in the north east and south of
the country
this is kharkiv ukraine's second city
it's like some sort of apocalypse the
man says
then overnight the violence even moved
west
these images purport to show an attack
on a military airfield in the city of
lutsk
one of two hit in this part of the
country
for families living nearby there was
shock and fear
of
she said some of her neighbors have fled
while she plans to spend the night with
her daughter in the city
the airfield that was hit is over there
behind me it's a military facility so
we're not allowed any closer but the
fact that russia has decided to target
military airfields in the west of the
country is a widening of the offensive
that for more than two weeks now has
been targeted on the north east and
south and it could also be designed to
send a message that nowhere in this
country is safe
and it's a sign russia wants to prevent
ukraine's air force from operating
something its invading forces have so
far failed to do
for officials here they're on a war
footing in case more violence comes
their way
it's the next stage of
the war
so it's uh
to know some
normal or
it's a second it's the second step so
the first step was in the north east and
the south and now it's in the world i do
believe yes and so do you expect there
will be more attacks in the west
we may expect anything from the russia
they don't have any
normal
logistic plan they
they can do horrible things
moscow says this shows its troops moving
towards kiev
but ukraine's military is defending hard
prompting fears russia will fight dirty
there's concern about chemical weapons
bringing mercenaries from syria and also
getting next door belarus to send in
soldiers
yet ukraine's president sounds more
confident than ever
it's impossible to say how many days we
will still need to free our land but it
is possible to say that we will do it
because we strive for that because we
have reached a strategic turning point
we are already moving towards our goal
towards our victory
it's an effort consuming everyone here
in the western city of lev one of the
safest parts of the country women and
men are learning how to shoot
if the war comes their way they say
they'll be ready debra haynes sky news
live